[Music]
on this Sunday night Ontario's struggle
with reopening and community spread the
crowded parks in the province where
coronavirus cases are rising again that
was absolutely shocked we just can't
have that right now and the Premier's
plea to get tested the legal fight over
allowing church services in the US where
parishioners are at risk Plus how
Canada's politicians will stay apart and
still get the work done in Parliament
during a pandemic and the heartfelt
homecoming for Captain killed in the
snowbirds plane crash
global national with Robin Gil
good evening and thank you for joining
us we begin in Halifax tonight for an
emotional homecoming
captain gen Casey a member of the
Canadian Forces snowbirds team killed in
a crash one week ago has returned to the
city where her life began family friends
members of the snowbirds team
governor-general Julie Payette and
defense minister Harjit Sajjan were
there to pay tribute to Casey she was
born and raised in Halifax and her
parents say it will be her final resting
place
[Music]
Casey was killed after ejecting from a
snowbirds plane in Kamloops BC the plane
was taking off for a final flight to
Vancouver Island she helped organize the
snowbirds cross-country campaign called
Operation inspiration intended to lift
the spirits of Canadians no matter how
we train we know that there are risky
parts within this job and that's why I'm
so proud of them and I hope they go
flying and and the fact that this
happened during Operation inspiration
where they were going around cheering us
Canadian as is even more touching
today the streets of Halifax were filled
with people paying their respects to
Casey the 35 year old was the snowbirds
public affairs officer and a former
journalist
the motorcade passed by the places that
were significant to her including the
home where she grew up and the radio
station where she worked as a journalist
before joining the Armed Forces now to
the Cova 19 pandemic the lifting of
restrictions brings the risk that the
number of cases could climb this weekend
crowds at a Toronto Park sparked
national concern that new freedoms could
trigger a second wave one that could be
worse and put a huge burden on the
healthcare system and that concern can
be seen in the latest number of cases
Ontario reported 460 new cases of Kovan
19 today the highest single day rise in
more than two weeks there are now more
than 25,000 cases in that province right
across the country Canadians are
watching to see if infection rates can
be controlled and still allow the
economy to get back on track
here's Heather York's West
after weeks under lockdown and with the
enticement of summer son Matt Nomura and
his partner are happy to be outside a
lot of people are today which is nice to
see
calgary's riverwalk was a popular place
Sunday though people appeared to be
following physical distancing guidelines
a far cry from the scene in this Toronto
Park on Saturday you know I thought it
was a rock concert at the beginning when
I went out there I was absolutely
shocked the images came as a shock to
some frontline health workers too I'm
really saddened when I see that because
I wonder if those people know the
sacrifices that people like myself my
colleagues in emergency room and the ICU
are making
Toronto is already seeing rising case
numbers official suspect may be
connected to gatherings on Mother's Day
if we see a little bit of a spike in
cases but it's something that's easy to
contain and that's okay that leeway was
okay but that's the reason why that this
has to be something that's constantly
being evaluated we'll be tracking and
tracing across the country how cases are
tracked and reported varies
significantly in Toronto more localized
numbers aren't available at all in BC
case numbers are only released for the
five health regions no specifics on
which communities have been impacted are
provided but in places like Calgary
Edmonton Montreal and Ottawa detailed
maps of case counts and outbreaks are
available to the public part of the
reason is because it gives people who
are not in those communities a false
sense of security that they don't have
the virus
and as restrictions lift doctor Henry
says everyone needs to stay on guard
bars restaurants and even Hair Salons
can reopen in Calgary starting on Monday
but across most of the rest of the
province these businesses have been open
now for more than a week
health officials say that based on early
data they don't appear to be
contributing to an increase in spread of
course that could change at any time
because without a vaccine the threat of
kovat 19:00 remains still after so long
at home there are many more anxious to
get back out there again maybe a patio
tomorrow if there's room I would imagine
this
be super busy though whether your exbest
global news Calgary the US has recorded
up to 25,000 new cases a day for the
past week it is the global epicenter of
the pandemic with more than 1.6 million
confirmed cases and the death toll is
getting closer to a hundred thousand
people but the lives lost are more than
just a number this is the front page of
today's New York Times it listed a
thousand names and something to remember
them by keep in mind this represents
only 1% of the overall death toll the
publication calls it an incalculable
loss that was meant to serve as a
reality check and still many churches in
the US are allowing parishioners to
return to places where closed gatherings
can only make the pandemic worse
President Donald Trump has deemed places
of worship and essential service despite
orders from some governors to keep them
closed as Jennifer Johnson reports
analysts believe Trump is appealing to
his conservative base as it gets ready
for an election from Arizona to
Minnesota to New Jersey u.s. houses of
worship are once again opening their
doors there's nothing like just
gathering again and just seeing friends
and families but there are new
precautions greeters and face masks some
limiting the number of attendees
handshaking and hugging discouraged
services spaced out to allow for
cleaning time people coming to our
church will have a touchless temperature
taken anybody 100.4 and above would not
be able to come into the church building
everybody coming into the church
building will wear masks on Friday u.s.
President Donald Trump in an apparent
appeal to his conservative base declared
houses of worship essential the
president overstepping the
constitutional rights and legal powers
of 50 state leaders if they don't do it
I will override the governor's that same
day a federal appeals court backed
California governor's ban on in church
services but other Democratic governors
reluctantly gave in
even as kovin 19 cases continue to rise
in their states we've got work to do
this is not over we have no vaccine we
still have no clear
therapeutic s-- public health experts
warned houses of worship are uniquely
prone to spreading koban 19 if strict
social distancing rules aren't followed
in March 1 positive choir member in
Seattle infected over fifty members two
died but some health officials recognize
the mental health benefits of reopening
mindful that that that worship is is
special plays a special role in in
health and well-being it's unclear
whether this controversial move will
cause a rise in covent 19 cases
supporters of reopening z' point to
preliminary data from georgia the first
u.s. date to open businesses last month
showing no major spike in köppen 19
cases worship leaders pray that will
hold true for their congregations to
Jennifer Johnson Global News Washington
what happened at a church in Germany is
an example of what can happen more than
40 people who attended a church service
in Frankfort have contracted Kovan 19
officials say physical distancing rules
were followed and the church was
disinfected prior to the service tonight
there are more than a hundred and eighty
thousand confirmed cases of Cova 19 in
germany and more than 8,000 people have
died
Spain is set to ease its lockdown in
Madrid and Barcelona starting tomorrow
Prime Minister Pedro Sanchez made the
announcement as protests took place
calling for his resignation over the
Spanish government's nationwide lockdown
which was one of the toughest in the
world and had a huge impact on jobs in
the economy in July Spain plans to allow
international tourism over the border in
France the government there is warning
its citizens not to travel abroad
suggesting they take their summer
holidays near home because around the
world the numbers are staggering
particularly in Russia which reported a
hundred and fifty three deaths in the
last 24 hours
there are now more than three hundred
and forty thousand confirmed cases in
that country but Brazil has overtaken
Russia becoming the second worst
affected country in the world with
350,000 cases more than 22,000 deaths
and there are fears cases will continue
to rise in Afghanistan which topped
10,000 today as Muslims begin to
celebrate Eid which is the end
ramadhan MPs are heading back to work
tomorrow in Ottawa while some of them
like many Canadians the pandemic has
forced our parliamentarians to work
under a different model the next sitting
of the House of Commons will look
different but as Abigail Beeman explains
negotiations are still under way among
the parties to determine exactly what
it'll look like
it's actually the NDP motion that's how
pleased the NDP are with the hybrid
Parliament motion the Liberals put
forward saying it incorporates much of
what they asked for but this is a
minority government meaning it's all
about negotiations with opposition
parties so the NDP are pushing for other
things more support for people with
disabilities and paid sick leave on the
procedural aspects there's no doubt but
we are primarily concerned about action
for people this is not what we want but
we do feel they've come a long way the
Conservatives have long been pushing for
Parliament to return with reduced
numbers rather than the special kovat 19
committee the House Leader says they're
not prepared to support what's on the
table I don't think you'll see
conservatives trying to block it or
obstruct it in a in a way that's
problematic but you will see
conservatives using the time available
to debate and talk about it and ask
questions the bloc québécois haven't yet
revealed their position the Greens will
vote in favour
they don't want an increase in in-person
sessions that I've had to leave British
Columbia and go to Ottawa to be in
Parliament I felt like you know I felt a
sense of real personal risk-taking and
personal responsibility not to expose
others the motion meets opposition
demands more power for committees the
opportunity to ask questions on topics
father than cope at 19 and some summer
sittings
it proposes for hybrid sessions of the
kovat special committee a week up from
three some MPs would attend in person
others virtually there will have to be a
way for parliamentarians across the
country to express the concerns and ask
questions on behalf of their
constituents these are the kinds of
things that we're working out an
unresolved item a committee has been
given a month to work out how to vote
virtually one Parliament
expert watching how countries adapt
around the world says he's not in favor
of that I have a lot of security and
technical issues as to how you're going
to ensure that those votes won't be
hacked or that we're going to ensure
that the members are themselves doing
the voting and there was a lot of
questions that needed to be unpacked
there so much to unpack in general when
the house returns in person on Monday
some expect debate on this motion to
last four days before a vote Robin
Abigail Beeman in Ottawa still ahead
thousand spark in defiance of China's
proposed national security law
police fired pellet guns teargas and a
water cannon at crowds of protesters
that swarmed some of Hong Kong's busiest
neighborhoods today thousands took to
the streets to march against Beijing's
plan to impose controversial national
security legislation it's the city's
first large-scale demonstration since
the outbreak of the new coronavirus
pandemic at least 180 people were
arrested mostly for unlawful assembly
North Korea has released footage
reportedly showing Kim jong-un chairing
a military meeting state media says the
meeting was to discuss bolstering the
country's nuclear arsenal and to put its
strategic armed forces on high alert
this is the North Korean leaders second
public appearance in over three weeks at
the beginning of the month state-run
media reported Kim had attended a
factory opening after rumors were flying
that he was gravely ill the historic
corruption trial for Israeli Prime
Minister Benjamin Netanyahu has begun
the seven-year-old was defiant in court
today lashing out at the country's
justice system
he's accused of fraud breach of trust
and accepting bribes Netanyahu says he's
innocent and the victim of a conspiracy
by police prosecutors and the media he's
the first sitting Prime Minister in
Israel to go on trial legal analysts
expect the case to last several years
still have the anatomy of a test a rare
look at the labs key to fighting this
pandemic
more than 1.4 million Canadians have
been tested for Cova 19 of those tests
about 5% came back positive on average
there are 28,000 tests a day in Canada
but there is still a push to do more
Global News toured one facility that's
been given this task
here's Jeff sample Jeff Oh Robin we got
a rare look inside a part of the
hospital that is a patient you don't
often get to see the microbiology
laboratory inside Toronto's Humber River
Hospital where a team of lab
technologists and technicians are
working around the clock 24/7 testing
patient samples looking for a wide range
of ailments and different illnesses
everything from cancer to high
cholesterol now this is one of more than
two dozen labs here in Ontario that has
now been tasked with testing for Co vid
19 the lab is a high-tech operation
that's pretty amazing to watch frankly a
procession line of test tubes carrying
blood samples along this conveyor belt
each tube is labeled with a barcode that
gets automatically scanned and then sent
in different directions along the belt
depending on the test that's required
the whole process is almost completely
automated and this lab alone conducts
more than 2,000 tests every day but the
Cova Denine team tests involve a much
different operation on a much smaller
scale there's one machine that can test
sixteen samples at a time and as a
result the lab can only really process
around thirty Kovan 19 tests every day
and the tests themselves are in short
supply prior to this year there was
nobody developing that test so every
company that's now developing that test
has had to ramp up production their
supply chain issues and I do wish that
we had more testing capability Ontario
is one of the hardest-hit provinces by
this pandemic and it's also having the
toughest time with kovat 19 testing
lagging behind the other provinces and
failing to hit its own testing targets I
do
understand what's behind that backlog we
followed one kovat 19 tests right
through the system from the first swab
to the final result with a number of
stops in between and we will bring you
that story in our full report coming up
in a special program the new reality
Robin Jeff sample in Toronto Canada's
vulnerable communities are the most risk
of getting covin 19 tonight on the new
reality Donna Friesen talks with dr.
Andrew Missouri about the impact Kovan
19 is having on the marginalized here's
an excerpt for people who aren't on the
frontlines like you are can you explain
how the lack of safe housing and poverty
intersect to put people at greater risk
of getting kovat 19 Colvin has you know
torn back the curtain on any sort of way
to ignore this of any sort of way not to
see the connection if an individual is
experiencing homelessness they do not
have places to physically isolate they
are constantly at risk they are
constantly in situations where they're
not able to also have any usual or what
we would hope for health care delivery
or in health care access and then I
think the other challenge on this has
also been it's for the under house right
as well that we're seeing these issues
of where physical distancing is a
privilege it has not been afforded to
all and what we're seeing it come up
with kovat is that it's really coming at
the cost and the expense of the poor
there needs to be an opportunity for
individuals to have the human dignity
and the protection that we would expect
and demand for everybody living in
Canada has not played out so I think you
know from you know again there is
incredible heroism by the individuals
who are experiencing this every hour of
the day who have had to look out for
family members for themselves there is
incredible courage by the frontline
shelter staff by community workers who
are in shelters who are in the
facilities to do all that they can to
help individuals from our health care
workers and hospitals and you can watch
the full interview right here on global
on the new reality
up next Pelican problems have a few
Canadians came to the rescue of an
endangered animal
[Music]
this year's Eid festivities marking the
end of Ramadan look very different for
Muslims around the world in Mecca the
Grand Mosque was almost empty few were
allowed in the usually packed place of
worship because of endemic restrictions
the Muslim Association of Canada is
hosting virtual festivities and prayers
allowing many across this country to
celebrate online American white pelicans
mostly winter in California but they can
be found in one part of BC when they
need to breed last fall one of those
rare Birds separated from its flock and
was found near death it has since
undergone months of rehab of Lynda
Ellsworth reports wildlife crews managed
to locate its flock so they could be
reunited it is a moment seven months and
several tens of thousands of dollars in
the making inside the kennel an
endangered American white pelican
discovered last October on a beach near
Oliver the locals there called us very
concerned because this one Pelican was
left behind when the rest of his flock
had left on their migration down to
California for the winter Wildlife
Rescue Association volunteers drove six
hours from Burnaby to assess the
situation the Pelican was quite thin
dehydrated there was wounds and blood
and injuries so we knew that this
colicky needed help immediately it
looked like a discarded fish hook and
line snagged on its wing tearing the
skin away rehabilitation was going to
take a while so they built Pelle
as he or she became known a special
enclosure complete with swimming pool
they're not a lot of time is spent on
their feet so it was really important to
keep him on the water off his feet so he
didn't get any leg or feet injuries even
after Pelle recovered from the wound and
emaciation the rehabilitation continued
what we what I do is really hit those
preconditioning release requirements so
the perching the self feeding exercises
the wings
after that it was a matter of waiting
for police flop to return to their
breeding grounds on punsie lake in the
central interior which at long last they
have to see him flap his wings really
nice and strong and finally when he
glided in the water it was just really
amazing to see him it was emotional
definitely tears all of us even more
tears when like in a storybook another
Pelican emerged and the two swam off
together into the distance
Linda Ellsworth Global News Vancouver
and that is global national for this
Sunday I'm Robin Gill tonight your
Canada is the cloudy sky over Peggy's
Cove thank you for watching good night
[Music]